make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay
so i was informed that i had not
recorded
or at least the audio that i'd recorded
for uh the great society was the wrong
audio or at least when i uploaded was
the wrong audio and i switched computers
so now i have to re-record it which
really isn't that bad because i kind of
didn't really even like the first
recording that i did
i know it sounds terrible to say you
guys would be amazed how often i record
a video and then realize there's
something about it i don't like
and re-record it like you guys be amazed
how often i do that but for those of you
guys who
are not even really joining us uh but i
guess if you guys are joining us you
know you have the collapse of the
multiverse the various incursions that
are happening which means basically
earth from alternate realities crashing
into each other and what we had here
was reed richards building what was
called a bridge and this bridge
basically served the purpose of allowing
the new avengers the illuminati whatever
you want to call them to
essentially peer into other universes to
see how
other universes are faring with the
incursions because one of the things
that they were told by black swan at the
beginning of all this right when we
covered the very first volume of this
the collapse of the multiverse all that
kind of stuff how it was all ending the
introduction of black swan as a new
character
she basically iterated or really kind of
provided us with this scenario that in
other universes people respond to the
incursions in different ways
some people have used cosmic cubes other
other universes have done the exact same
thing that was done
in the main marvel universe where they
used an infinity gauntlet and things
didn't work that there are some
universes where people destroyed their
own earths and then took residence in a
new planet and when they did that
sometimes they would save the human uh
the humans on their world sometimes they
would just abandon it and just destroy
it and whoever you know and
just essentially save themselves there
were instances when other races would
destroy their earth when they figure out
what was going on that like galactus
would show up to earth and then
obliterated in order to save that
universe
we saw it playing out in different ways
and so the idea behind this bridge is to
to
basically in one way verify the
authenticity of what it was a black swan
set
and then two if there are other earths
out there that are basically solving the
incursions then figuring out how it is
that they're doing that right because
maybe they thought of something that
everybody here hasn't thought of yet and
so what it does is of course it
basically brings together
namor the submariner and black panther
now black panther is the one who at the
moment is cataloging these various
worlds and what he's found
is that world after world the ones that
you've seen really just kind of seem to
fall the same way that either they're
destroyed by the map makers they're
destroyed by the black priests which we
haven't really talked about in depth yet
but we will
they're kind of a special scenario and
in reality it wasn't really until
jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers ended that i actually realized
what the black priests were
right but we'll talk more about them
once we once we cross that bridge and
then of course
you know you basically end up having a
lot of the worlds that are i'm sorry a
lot of the universes that are being
destroyed when they're crashing into
each other
but there is one particular world that
uh t'challa came across
where they've survived not just one
incursion but two and so the question is
how in the world did they manage to pull
that off and so what hickman does is it
gives us a little bit of backstory here
and what we end up finding out is this
world is home to a group called the
great society now first things first the
great society is basically a stand-in
for the justice league is really all
they are and i'll talk more about that
here in a second but the cool thing
about this
is that what you had at some point in
time really about four years prior to
uh to what's going on at the moment or
maybe even a little bit longer than that
is you had what were called the
archetypes of justice now the indication
here
is this is the only superhero team that
existed on earth it was basically
wolverine
psylocke that reality's version of namo
the submariner and a couple others
but what you ended up having is what
jonathan hickman refers to as
xenogeneticist it was basically a
combination of the cree and the scrolls
working together is basically what it is
now we're not given a lot of backstory
here we don't know what really led to
this conflict we don't know what led to
the cree and the scroll teaming up and
basically working with each other
against the
against the superheroes on earth we
don't really know what the case is but
what we do know is that these
superheroes
basically fell now assuming there were
no x-men that there were no
justice league or anything like that
that basically these superheroes fell
and the world was successfully conquered
by the cree and the scrolls we can
largely assume
superheroes other superheroes did exist
for a couple different reasons uh one
is because in the fall of the archetypes
of justice we saw the rise of the great
society
and two it just makes good sense right
to just believe that other superheroes
existed it just seems reasonable but the
reality of this and the important thing
here
is that when the earth was conquered or
at least this alternate reality was
conquered by the creed and the scrolls
the great society rose up
basically as it's kind of like a group
of outcast superheroes that essentially
cast off the kree and the scrolls and
then saved the world and so following
that they ushered in what was called
this this great society in the sense
that it was a it was kind of in
an age of enlightenment right so like
the science games championing the
advancement of human potential different
things along those lines and so these
guys were basically the new wave the new
crop of superheroes and have kind of
been leading the world ever since
saving the planet from a multitude of
different threats but the important
thing here is what we end up doing is
basically picking up with
with a guy by the name of wayne now
wayne also goes by the name ryder and he
is basically batman in this particular
universe what we also know is that some
kind of an event had basically taken
place
where about a hundred men women and
children had died and the results of
this is that wayne routinely goes back
and visits this marker as a way to honor
their memory right so it seems to have
been a mistake that he made that led to
them dying and this is a very important
element because what it does is it shows
the humanity behind the characters that
with us not really knowing a whole lot
about them we wouldn't really know if
they were good guys or bad guys whatever
the case was
you know if the the rise of them in
terms of saving the earth led to them
becoming these these sort of you know
almost fascist kind of guys we don't
really know but what we do know now is
that they're basically good guys
now the other part of this is that a
character by the name of the norn had
basically
more or less told by virtue of his
powers that another incursion was
happening so it's the great society's
version of an early warning system but
the norn is a stand-in for doctor fate
and and so with this happening of course
you have a coming together of the
various guys who were here and that's
what we really sort of get this full-on
explanation or at least this this full
kind of depiction of the fact they are
more or less the justice league right
the writer is batman
boundless is basically the flash the
jovian is martian manhunter the norn
is dr fate sun god is essentially
superman and doctor spectrum is
basically the green lantern and so much
like we've seen with
with you know the the main illuminati
themselves you kind of get a speech
about you know the the collapse of the
multiverse but the difference here
is that the great society looks at this
from the perspective of everything lives
right so they're far more
far more optimistic they're they're
really they really are just legitimate
good guys
the other cool thing about this is that
once they end up teleporting to what is
essentially
the incursion wall which as you guys
recall is a kind of barrier
right so if your left hand is is one
universe and your right hand is another
what you have is a point where your
hands are on the verge of touching what
the incursion wall does is it allows you
to pass from your left hand to your
right hand right it just allows you to
move from one universe to the next and
so once they actually get inside that
universe and they see that earth then
now they realize it's an incursion of
map makers and this is important this is
hugely important because one of the
things to keep in mind is again the map
makers
are wildly powerful beings and in every
other alternate universe the illuminati
have looked at and they've seen the map
makers arrive
it basically signals the absolute death
of every superhero who's there
the map makers automatically react to
the powers of the various people who are
there
they augment themselves modify
themselves they overcome those powers
and then they destroy them and then they
destroy the world
no one ever really succeeds in their
conflict against the map makers but
the great society seems to know of them
and the great society
has basically found a way to overcome
them and you would think that it would
be virtue of some kind of scientific
achievement or they have something like
the ultimate nullifier or something like
that you know their realities version of
this device they can essentially
obliterate anything from existence and
basically make it as if it never was
you would think it would be something
like that no it's just the sheer force
of their power that's
all it is it's just the complete and
total power that they have
and so what you end up finding out is
that one of these guys is actually
donning a helmet of the black priest and
the reason why this matters is because
they successfully managed to repel or at
least destroy the bridge builders right
the forerunners of the map makers the
the bridge builders for those of you
guys who don't remember are the ones who
basically show up first
you know whenever you have a blue earth
they're the ones who basically show up
on the new earth they basically wipe out
all the superheroes and then they
basically tell the map makers hey here's
a spot for you to come to then the map
makers show up and essentially kill any
superheroes that the bridge builders
couldn't destroy the bridge builders are
obliterated that blue earth is destroyed
and then that leads to the arrival of
the map makers and more so than that the
map makers get totally destroyed but
what are you end up finding out here is
that the the great society has actually
figured things out they figured out that
like the ability for the map makers to
adapt
is based on a piece of technology inside
their own bodies right that before they
can adapt to their powers to rip that
out to basically destroy the
computer components inside their bodies
essentially right their intelligence
core whatever you want to call it but to
rip that out before the map makers can
respond is the best thing that's one of
the reasons why soundless is so
important here because
she's able to move so astronomically
fast that she can basically act before
the map makers have time to
from there it turns to sun god and
that's when you really get kind of a
full-on display of this guy's power
because if the fight goes on too long
these map makers would probably
overpower the the great society right
they would kind of continue to adapt but
sun god basically channels all the solar
energy in his body and lets off this
enormous flare with the rest of the
superhero team being protected by uh by
dr spectrum and then of course all the
map makers are completely and totally
obliterated and that's what makes things
kind of bonkers here is because
you have namor and you have to challa
who are watching all this go down
and it's like okay so like these guys
are for real like these guys
are serious contenders but notice this
is the funny thing that you
that you do not see here neither of them
entertains the idea
of joining forces but what you do end up
getting is a really cool conversation
that goes on here because namo the
submariner has become a lot more
pessimistic or
you could argue realistic than black
panther has because for all the vaunted
wisdom of black panther for all the
blunted wisdom of t'challa right in the
sense he's so smart and all that kind of
stuff at the end of the day he's still
hopeful the response of namor is that
hope is the
is the refuge of dying men hope is what
you have when you have nothing else left
but that's not the reality of the
situation that we're in here you know
the reality that we're in here is we're
fighting against hopeless odds we're
like these guys
we have a small victory in a war that
we're going to lose
these guys are going to lose this
conflict they're going to lose this war
so they can celebrate all they want to
and their achievement and
overcoming the map makers but it won't
matter because the multiverse is going
to end
anyway it's a very dark perspective to
have but t'challa really kind of comes
back at that and says no but
it's us as people and what we do in this
circumstance is how we respond to it
that define us as people
everything was going to end anyway it
was inevitable that the multiverse was
going to end it was inevitable that even
if the multiverse didn't end that our
universe was going to end and the face
of that knowledge does it mean that we
just give up right if we
if we knew with absolute certainty that
the universe would end which it will
does that mean that we just refuse to
live right it'll be billions of years
billions and billions and millions of
years before that happens or at least
under any normal circumstance it would
be with the incursions it shrinks at a
geometric rate right like it strengthens
it
in a massive margin but you know he's
like if we're born into this world and
then we learn science and we realize
that through that science that our
universe is going to end at some point
does that mean that at whatever point we
learn that we just sit down and die no
we live our lives right we become
honorable people we have families and
all that kind of stuff because one we
know that we're not going to have to
worry about seeing the death of those
families anytime
soon but two even though we know our
family line will die
that life is still worth living that is
still worth it to be
an honorable and a good person and
that's really what it kind of hits that
here that you look at this as though
because of the fact that all hope is
lost because of the fact there really is
no means to save the multiverse you know
because it is inevitably going to die
that we should somehow just give up on
who we are and just
do whatever needs to be done in order to
save the day it's us as kings of our
respective kingdoms that make us great
men because of the actions and the deeds
that we do and namor comes back
with this amazing point and he says yes
we were kings and what are we now
we're kings of dead kingdoms right we
are kings of men who don't really have
anything to call
our own right we're people who are just
you know watching other universes die
and hoping that we can somehow find a
way to save our own all the while
this little voice in the back of our
head keeps growing bigger with every
incursion that we encounter
and every universe that we see destroyed
and it's saying there's no hope here
there's no way for you guys to win
you're fighting against a hopeless cause
and so with that being the case you know
as this is this kind of monitoring of
the great society's universe can you
know continues on that that suddenly
black panther is like name where you
need to look at this
and it's kind of like okay like what am
i seeing here right with the two of them
looking at something it's like what in
the heck am i seeing here like is this
the past because if it's the past none
of this really seems familiar and
black panther's response is no this is
two hours from now and what we
what we're basically told here by
hickman is that in two hours the
illuminati are going to confront the
great society
and the battle to save one of these
worlds is gonna take place right so
who wins marvel's new avengers or dc's
justice league
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
guys are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
you